alors voici l'ensemble compose le foll
donc là nous avons un stabilisateur donc
sous le nom dit bien sa fonction c'est
pour stabiliser l'ensemble
là nous avons les importantes donc la
plus grande qui sert justement à voler
voler si ce qu espère faire thomas
lequesne pendant près de dix heures nous
avons le mât mais voler en planche à
voile
l'exploit s'ils le réussis sera inédit
le taux de la martinique en winphone
dans le sens des aiguilles d'une montre
ça permet tout simplement de naviguer au
dessus de l'eau
donc ne plus avoir tous les problèmes
justement de clapot ça permet de partir
beaucoup plus vite aussi avec très peu
de vent au planning c'est des nouvelles
technologies qui permettent de repousser
les limites justement du score et
repousser les limites
c'est ce qui lui plaît pour ce faire
thomas était coachée par son ancien
moniteur de planche à voile un certain
rémi ville
quatre fois champion du monde dans les
années 90 et 2000 vingt fois champion de
la martinique
les longues distances et les défis il
connaît mais il en connaît aussi les
pièges dans une tentative comme celle ci
il ne faut pas beaucoup de vent parce
que sinon tu t'épuises trop rapidement
et le truc est très important dans un
tour de la martinique c'est pas une
épreuve de vitesse c'est une force
d'endurance le risque c'est d'être
l'épuisement et surtout le soleil alors
le solex le plus gros combat a fait sur
un taureau parce que c'est une longue
distance et le soleil détruit très
rapidement c'est toutes les forces
il faut bien se protéger ou garder son
énergie dimanche sur les coups de 6
heures du matin thomas lequel se jettera
à l'eau depuis le club nautique de
schelcher direction le nord pour être
très vite confronté aux premières
difficultés à commencer par le passage
sous le vent de la plaie mentalement ça
va me décharger de commencer par le plus
dur est de finir par le plus simple
donc je préfère commencer par là par
l'appeler le plus compliqué après il ya
le passage
côte atlantique où là je vais sûrement
rencontrer les sargasses même si on est
dans une période assez creuse on en a
quand même
- oui c'est vrai le côté physique ça
reste un challenge moqueur j'espère que
physiquement je saute en 2015 marcos
guedes avait établi le record à 14h35
pour un tour en planche à dérive dit
classique sur ton foil thomas lequesne
espère le boucler en 10 heures avec donc
un retour à terre à lens madame en fin
d'après midi aux alentours de 16 heures